so not a lot of people know this but
back in 2019 Microsoft invested a
billion dollars in open AI this is the
company that made Dolly the AI art
generator and chat GPT the AI chatbot
we've been seeing everywhere now there's
rumors that they're going to invest an
additional 10 billion dollars for a 49
stake which you know sounds like boring
corporate and all that stuff but hear me
out AI across all of Microsoft's stuff
it makes so much sense so Microsoft Word
could have built-in text generation to
help you write things and brainstorm
essays Microsoft Outlook could help you
write emails and find excuses to get out
of meetings Microsoft PowerPoint could
of course have Dali AI generated clipart
but my favorite possibility and I swear
Microsoft should actually do this bring
back clippy some of y'all might not be
old enough to remember clippy but clippy
was this paperclip virtual assistant
that would pop up in Microsoft apps and
try to help you out it was kind of
low-key annoying but bring back clippy
with all the smarts of chat GPT and
maybe you can even generate some images
too dude Microsoft there's no reason not
to and we'll forget Cortana ever existed